we realize that we will never be able to
go back to life pre covet 19 we have to
live with this risk privacy is a very
important human right but it is not an
absolute right have you sacrificed calls
to improve human rights in order to keep
the dialogue going well you keep saying
concerned we're not concerned South
Korea has been hailed as a model country
in bringing its coronavirus infection
rate under control but the methods have
raised privacy and public shaming
concerns and now there are reports that
the virus is back again my guest this
week is South Korean Foreign Minister
Kang quinoa has her government made too
many compromises on citizens privacy in
its efforts to contain the pandemic and
how could the public health crisis
impact diplomacy in the region and
beyond especially with its nuclear
neighbor to the north
[Music]
foreign minister Chung kyung-wha welcome
to conflict zone thank you for having me
your country has reported a flare-up in
coronavirus cases this week around the
capital at a number of nightclubs which
authorities are now temporarily closing
president moon has warned a second wave
is coming whether now or in the future
this at a time when you were just
starting to ease some pandemic
restrictions how concerned is your
government over the threat of a second
outbreak very concerned but we have been
guarding against this possibility this
virus is very tricky it's it spreads
very careful very fast and it's spread
silently asymptomatic people can be can
be contagious so we've been guarding
against this possibility it's very
unfortunate that this has happened but
our system is now fully up and running
to trace to test and of course to treat
the confirmed patients this is a
population that we have been concerned
about all along you know young people
nighttime clubs where lots of people
gather and evidently where the sanitary
rules were not strictly abided by they
were instructed to keep a closed list of
all the visitors to take all precautions
but it turns out that these measures
weren't adhered to and now we are
dealing with a huge population that need
to be traced and tested so given that I
mean you initially managed to come to
grips with the pandemic through without
any extensive long downs we have to see
which we saw elsewhere you said in a
recent interview that you didn't think
the idea of a lockdown or a blockade
would be acceptable to your public that
this idea of a mandatory blockade would
really be contracted contradictory to
the principle of openness do you think
that you might have to rethink that
policy in the face of the second wave
well I think this the measures that we
have taken in the in the immediate
aftermath of this outbreak is closure of
these
entertainment facilities and these are
by city administrative decree here in
Seoul in other big cities as well so it
is a temporarily shutdown of these
entertainment establishments it is not a
wholesale lockdown of businesses and I
don't think we will ever get to that
point we are racing against time in in
tracking down all the close contacts of
people who have been to these
establishments during this particular
period which was a long holiday just
before we were hoping to go to and it's
in an easier form of social distancing
and we have gone into that for the rest
of society what we call distancing in
everyday life and this is this means
that we realize that we will never be
able to go back to life
Priya Cove at 19 we have to live with
this risk and be prepared when it raises
its head again obviously this time it
has raised it set in big numbers but I
think we are prepared and we are we are
doing our very best to contain this
outbreak let's talk a little bit more
about some of the the measures that your
public is also living with the recent
flare-up in cases it's further
highlighted some glaring privacy issues
with the track and trace methods that
you're using to contain the pandemic
enough details are being released to the
public where people's whereabouts their
identities are being revealed and I'd
like to bring up this example because
it's been reported that one of the
recent coronavirus cases was a man who
attended clubs in Seoul's gay district
now rights groups fear that you know
efforts are going to be made to forcibly
out gay people who came in contact with
him does it highlight a major failure in
privacy protections I think the issue of
privacy has been taken out of context
the issue of privacy is with certainly
the patients and I think we do this by
law privacy is a very important human
rights but it is not an absolute right I
think the ICCPR makes this very
clear that it can be restricted but it
has to be resisted in accordance with a
law we have a very robust legal system
in place where it's clearly identified
as to where these rights might be
restricted and when you balance the
privacy of the patients against the
public's need to be protected from this
race I think the answer is very clear so
the problem is so it's no for you
obviously you do it by law it's okay for
you that some social media users they've
already posted video footage of some of
the gay bars and clubs urging followers
for donations to quote help put a stop
to these disgusting going ons that's an
acceptable practice it is not okay it is
not okay
I think discrimination prejudice against
people for who they are is unacceptable
for a country that is committed on the
fundamental values of human rights that
undergirds our democracy it is not
acceptable but I think we you know and
this is what the government is guarding
against that you know this we don't have
a consensus on the rights of the sexual
minorities and people with various
gender identities we don't have a
consensus we acknowledge that but the
changes take over to you know take time
and I think pushing for changes to
prematurely can create a backlash that
is even more harmful but here we are we
are faced with this challenge and the
government response is very careful
about not aggravating those existing
prejudices and we're hoping that through
this experience we will dispelled
a lot of the prejudice and
discrimination that the sexual
minorities are faced with going to clubs
it's not just people with us different
sexual it-it-it's
everybody going to these clubs so we're
tracking down everybody that have been
involved in the club activities during
this holiday time but it's not just
clubs it's not just LGBT communities I
mean I'd like to just ask you about the
the environment that this is creating in
your society because a recent study
found that citizens are more afraid of
being socially sit shamed for example
for having us
the virus than they are of the disease
itself so what does that say about the
environment that these measures have
created in society right now
I think our measures have been open more
open than many of the measures that
other societies have taken obviously in
the situation of crisis people have
stress issues to deal with there is a
psychological element that this crisis
has created that all societies have have
to face we are trying to face that with
the best of our expertise in in terms of
the psychological counselling that we
provide to our citizens and anybody who
is in need we have a system obviously
that may not be enough but I think we
have we have a system and we are dealing
with it and I think if this is a
challenge not just for us but for all
countries and I think the the this the
COBIT 19 has also made clear that you
know there are there are hidden spots
blind spots in society that are revealed
when a crisis comes along like this you
know that the we have some of our dark
spots as well for example eulogy has
something like 400,000 yes yes we are
you know and this is not just
government's that a person alone because
there's a limitation as to how far the
government's efforts can reach we enlist
a great deal of support from our civil
society groups who are helping for
example undocumented workers who are
helping the sexual minority groups as
well we are enlisting their help so that
people can come forward feeling safe to
undergo testing entry okay so we we
talked about democratic values we talked
about the balance between privacy and
public health as you've articulated
there I'd like to speak now about the
dictatorship to the north first of all
in the past weeks a lot of speculation
about leader Kim jong-un's health
recently your intelligence has said that
there were no signs that he had surgery
how sick was he or is
well you know our intelligence is robust
and we share and analyze a great deal
together with our ally the United States
and all indications we have is that
there is no unusual activity whether
it's it's his health for our the society
as a whole
obviously there's a limitation because
it's a closed society and information is
very difficult to garner but to the
extent that we know there you know we
don't detect any unusual developments
it's a closed society that your
administration has been has been making
major efforts to crack open since
President moon took office in 2017 your
government has stressed improving ties
with the north in the hopes of promoting
peace on the peninsula but but you've
been criticized over not putting human
rights high enough up on the agenda for
example you dropped the traditional
co-sponsoring of a resolution condemning
North Korea's horrific rights record at
the UN General Assembly this past fall
president moon also did not bring up
human rights in a meeting with Kim
jong-un last year have you sacrificed
calls to improve human rights in order
to keep the dialogue going I think
keeping the dialogue going is extremely
important if we are going to find a
peaceful resolution with the North
Korean nuclear and missiles issue and
and getting us on track towards creating
lasting peace on the Korean Peninsula
human rights is a very big issue when it
comes to North Korea and we support the
international efforts the UN efforts in
this regard obviously to keep the
engagement going we have to balance
everything and it's a decision given all
the consideration that the judgments
that we make we do not it's not that we
don't consider a human rights issue of
North Korea any less but in the tactics
and the strategy in promoting the
engagement with North Korea has to weigh
all factors and proceed but there's a
critical mass of criticism I just like
to highlight a couple of them because
the United Nations Special Rapporteur on
human rights in
North Korea has said the following
integrating fundamental human rights
into the current negotiations is crucial
crucial for the sustainability of any
agreement for denuclearization and peace
on the Korean Peninsula and beyond
can you really wait to talk tough on
human rights with North Korea I mean
doesn't that undermine the legitimacy of
your efforts I don't think so I think
Human Rights has a place and I think the
human rights mechanisms of the United
States the United Nations plays a very
important role in keeping the engagement
on that track but there's a another
track to engagement with North Korea
which is the peace and security track
and at some point they have to come
together but at this time we are
judgment is that the the security track
has to take precedence you've also been
heavily criticized as you are
prioritizing that security track of
turning a blind eye in another way back
in November your country deported two
fishermen accused of murder back to
North Korea the UN again expressing deep
concern that quote the decision was made
potentially without due process and that
the two men are at risk of serious human
rights violations upon return and and
they just highlight a couple including
enforced disappearance arbitrary
execution torture ill treatment trials
that do not conform to international
fair trial standards they say that your
government could have failed to uphold
international human rights obligations
itself do you regret that deportation
decision no not at all I think we made
the best decision under the
circumstances and given that there was
no genuineness to the to men's desire to
come to this part of the peninsula and
given that adjudication themselves have
well there's a we have a we have a
proceed process run by our national
security
office and all the ministries are
involved and the collective decision was
that they pose a danger to our society
and that's so therefore the decision was
made it doesn't it really come down to
the fact that you're afraid that any
position that you that you take on human
rights will simply blow up talks with
the north we are not afraid we are we
are very actively seeking the engagement
taking all elements into consideration
but I think even the human rights
mechanisms would say that it is very
important to keep that engagement going
okay I also like to talk about the
circumstances currently in the north I
mean we we highlighted a number of the
dire circumstances when it came to the
case of those two fishermen we also have
signs of deterioration there the country
has had a poor harvest season now with
coronavirus they are destabilizing
factors both economically potentially on
the health front as well how concerned
are you that the north with its
strongman policy will lash out and
deflect from the interior issues that it
has in the country well we watch very
carefully I think you know the official
position is that there is no case of
coronavirus but they report to the w-h-o
of quarantine people and and testing so
we take their official position with a
lot of grain of salt the health
structure there is extremely weak we
have offered to collaborate on this
fronts we have not received a response
yet but I would be cautious as to make
sweeping judgments about what the
situation there overall is but are you
preparing for the potential of increased
provocations well they have provoked
there has been a series of short-range
launches and you know these are
certainly unhelpful and we have urged
them to stop this is at a time when the
whole world is are trying to come to
grips with this
this very unprecedented health crisis
but we watch very closely and we are
prepared and I think based upon our very
robust defense posture and and readiness
based upon our strong us-rok security
alliance let's talk a little bit more
about that Alliance and your readiness
TIFF to face any potential threat from
the north you've mentioned that they've
already provoked you have actually been
trimming back on some joint military
exercises in an effort to engage the Kim
regime in dialogue the Carnegie
Endowment for international peace I said
the following about that pairing back
cancelling crucial exercises to tracks
from Seoul's very ability to manage the
threatening neighbor it has been
engaging with by downgrading South
Korea's military readiness and
compromising its ability to conduct
operations with US forces aren't you
concerned that you might not be ready if
Kim lashes out I have full confidence in
our military authorities in
collaboration with the US military
authorities to keep up that robust
preparedness despite the re construction
of the exercises you know the that is
done to support the diplomatic tracks
certainly but all the while making sure
that the preparedness is not in any way
undermined but it doesn't help
certainly that your relations with the
United States are not as good as they
once were you're currently at odds over
the defense cost-sharing the US has
rejected your offer of a 13 percent
increase in spending and instead is
demanding a five-fold increase how do
you want to come to an agreement and
what happens if you don't difficult I
admit but you know this is an alliance
that's developed over 67 years there
have been difficult issues in the past
that we've been able to work through you
know align a la allies have differences
and and I think the special measures
agreement this time is particularly
difficult but we are both the term
to find an agreement that we both can
agree to obviously it will take more
time and more effort but we are you know
I'm very confident that we will reach an
agreement
eventually Donald Trump has said the
following it's a question of whether
South Korea will contribute toward the
defense of their own nation we are
defending nations that are very wealthy
South Korea is a very wealthy nation
does he have a point we are increasingly
wealthy which is why our share of the
defense the stationing of the troops
have have increased over the years
initially the initial agreement is that
we will provide the land and the
facilities and the u.s. will provide for
the expenses of the troops stationing
now as Korea developed and became more
wealthy we have agreed to a special
measures agreement which is which is the
the title of this this Agreement and
increasingly more more of that share and
with that share that increase has to be
incremental it can't be 30 percent 50
percent over a one-year period there is
a methodology system there is a
budgetary system that our government has
to follow and in the end this has to go
through the National Assembly for
approvals so there are all these
parameters that we as government needs
to meet while negotiating with the
United States and I think our partners
across the table from the United States
are fully aware of this and as you're
sorting those through those parameters
we have the u.s. president not missing
one opportunity to say what a great
relationship he has with the North
Korean leader Kim jong-un and what a
nice guy he is Trump has said the
following we fell in love no really he
wrote me beautiful letters are you
concerned that Trump is speaking in such
high terms about the dictator to the
north and not about the democratically
elected president of South Korea I mean
your longtime allies well how do you
keep saying concern we're not concerned
I think the the relations between our
two governments at all levels
between the presidents between myself
and the Secretary of State is very
strong very tight and I think in
particular during this time of the COBIT
19 crisis the collaboration has been
exemplary so I'm not concerned I think
that's president Trump's unique way of
messaging and it also indicates his
clear desire to continue to engage at
that level the engagement with North
Korea this time around has been driven
very much by that top-level political
will both on the site of the United
States and also to a certain extent on
this part of our side as well so and
it's very important to keep that high
level political will
going for the continued engagement what
other options you have if if that you
know if that alliance breaks down I mean
have you become too reliant on the US
nuclear shield that they provide I am
not at all concerned about I don't think
that's up that's a scenario that we
anticipate I think we the Alliance is
very strong the u.s. is fully committed
to this the security of the the current
the South Korea and and the extension of
their their nuclear shield so I don't
know where you get that the possibility
of that happening I don't see that
possibility let's talk about China
because in the meantime China has been
using the coronavirus crisis as an
opportunity to assert itself in the
region there there's been an arrest the
arrest rather of democracy activists in
Hong Kong military pressure being put on
Taiwan and its neighbors in the South
China Sea even going so far as to sink a
Vietnamese fishing vessel it looks like
China is using the corona virus pandemic
as a regional power grab while other
major powers are busy at home surely
that must raise some red flags for you
well China and we have art we had our
difficult time in 2016-2017 post my
president's visit in December 2017 I
think we are largely recovering the
close economic and people-to-people ties
as far as the corona 19 virus is
concerned
it first happened in China and we were
one of the first to be hit because we
have lots of people traveling from back
and forth to China and I think the
collaboration on the COBIT 19 has been
has been very good we press for quick
and prompt sharing of information we
underscore the importance of that and we
demonstrate that with our own actions
and and we urge that on the part of
China as well we have economies under
pressure right now amid this pandemic
citizens health at stake what do you
think your part of the world will look
like after this pandemic ends
I think post corona virus the world will
certainly be different from pre kovat 19
I think all economies have been severely
hit by this you know we are rolling out
domestic economic stimulus packages for
for our strategic industries for small
and medium businesses for furloughed
workers for for households but that can
only go to a certain extent we are very
dependent on the our trade our
investment ties with overseas so we very
much hope that that also recovers and we
can't do that by ourselves so I hope do
you hope that our partners will also see
the self-interest in an you know for you
know recovering the global value chains
that the the trade and investments the
business trips and and you know I think
we there's two trends I think yes there
are tendencies of countries to become
insular and and and shutting of the
doors and and and parochial but I think
there is also an understanding that and
the virus has made it so clear that
these challenges are cross-border it
doesn't stop at the border and you may
close the border but the virus still
gets in and so there is a increasing
call for global coordination at various
fora at the UN at the whu-oh at the g20
and we do hope that it
beyond the talk that there will be
greater multilateral collaboration in
overcoming not just the the health
crisis but also the socio-economic
crisis as well South Korean foreign
minister kang kyung-hwa thank you for
joining us on complex oh thank you
[Music]
you